foreign
[Music]
welcome fellow Cosmic explorers to
another episode of The Cosmic Chronicles
podcast where imagination meets reality
and science fiction comes to life I am
your host Quinn and I am joined by my
co-host James hey how's it going it's
going pretty good we are still on the
lookout for sponsors and I imagine that
we will be looking for sponsors for a
few months before we finally get
everything together so if you are still
interested in sponsoring the cosmic
Chronicles podcast you can email us at
cosmicchronicles podcast at gmail.com
and lastly you can find our podcast
wherever you get your podcast including
Spotify Apple podcast Amazon music
Google podcast and all around be sure to
also subscribe to our YouTube channel as
well
now our topic for today is the horrors
of the deep why the ocean is scary
now this is a topic we've always wanted
to cover
the ocean is a topic in various works of
Science Fiction and I would say a
sizable number if not the majority of
those Works highlight the fears that are
associated with the ocean
the ocean is Primal Godly Immortal and
ancient it is quite literally a consumer
of cities a bringer of death and
destruction and yet it also represents
life rebirth and renewal the ocean was
Mankind's first Frontier the first
humans who explored it knew not what
they would face would the Earth stop at
the horizon or did the depths reach out
into infinity and of course what exactly
waited within the oceans seemingly
bottomless depths from the very first
time mankind laid eyes upon the ocean we
have wondered about what Mysteries it
held in this episode we will explore
these ideas through the lens of the
science fiction that we love
why do you think the ocean is scary well
like I said before I think the ocean
represents
one of the first Primal Mysteries that
mankind came into contact with so when I
think about early man there were really
two big Primal Mysteries that we first
encountered two things that invoked this
sense of awe and one of them was the
ocean and the other was the Sky Outer
Space you know the sons of God the moons
of God the stars are even Divine
um the ocean was another one of these
things but to me the ocean is a lot
scarier so basically essentially every
culture has um a god associated with
the ocean and that's because the ocean
is very angry the ocean is is a bringer
of storms the ocean is a consumer of
cities the ocean uh is sometimes coughs
up the dead
um it's it's an environment that's
completely inhospitable to humans and
there was initially like I said a lot of
mystery associated with the ocean and
there still is to this very day but with
early mankind people weren't even sure
if the ocean was gonna like I said end
at the Horizon people thought that maybe
if they continued on the ocean they
might just fall off the edge of the
Earth there is a lot of uncertainty so
you combine that just inherent
uncertainty and this inherent mystery of
the ocean with the fact that it is this
destructive force of Nature and it's
pretty easy to understand why the ocean
has always been scary so what do you
know about the Mariana Trench I know
that the Mariana Trench is the deepest
part of the ocean it is I know that it
is used in the movie mang yeah that's
where it takes away shark I know that uh
James Cameron director of Titanic at
Avatar has been to the Mariana trenches
and that is the extent of my knowledge
unfortunately yeah well it's at the
bottom of the Pacific Ocean
it's a huge huge Crescent and it's about
seven times the size of the Grand Canyon
Jesus huge yes that's about 1 589 miles
and the deepest part it's called the
Challenger Deep it's about seven miles
under the ocean in an area called The
hadel Zone which refers to the Greek god
Hades ruler of the underworld ah makes
perfect sense it's seven miles Jesus
seven miles deep yeah
um it's called the Challenger Deep
because it was discovered by the
Challenger Expedition it was a mission
of scientific discovery in 1875 they
were using a weighted rope to record the
depths of the ocean and when they got
over the Mariana Trench they put the
Rope over they had no idea what they
were over and they realized that they
needed more rope they had to run out of
Road they had run out of rope it was so
deep that's incredible but we didn't
actually uh go down there until
1960. we used a bath Escape do you know
what that is no what's a bath Escape uh
do you know what a pathy sphere is yeah
no okay so let's back up a bathy sphere
it's like literally a sphere that you
can sit inside and it's attached to a
boat on the surface and they would throw
you over the ledge and descend you down
into the ocean oh so it doesn't it
doesn't move itself it's just like
attached to it it doesn't move to itself
no it's just attached to the boat so you
basically can go down and watch what's
happening yeah so a bath Escape is
basically a submarine it's a free diving
self-propelled submersible and it's
suspended from a float that's on the
surface the bath Escape that went down
to the Mariana Trench was called the
triesta and it was designed by a
scientist named August Picard oh my God
like in Star Trek next Generation yeah
actually that's who Jean-Luc Picard is
named after let's press the scientist
yeah and then his son Jacques Picard was
the guy that actually went on the
triesta so jean-luca card designed it no
Jean-Luc Picard's the captain of the
Enterprise August Picard August Picard
designed this bath escape the triesta I
went down to the Mariana Trench so
August car designs it and then his son
Jacques
piccards the Explorer that went down
there very very interesting so on their
way down to the bottom of the Mariana
Trench the window started to crack
so they didn't last very long but they
they did get to the bottom
they lasted 20 minutes at the bottom
that sounds horrifying and so how long
ago was this what year was this exactly
oh this was in 1960
1960 yeah wow and they didn't expect to
find life when they got down there but
they did they found pale shrimp and flat
flounder-like fish
and then they also described a dark
brown
Diatomaceous ooze which is kind of like
a soft dirt made from fossilized remains
of tiny aquatic organisms that's like in
the movie The mag in the Meg they find
that too but they like go beneath yeah
and there's another world there's like a
Jules Verne situation there's like it it
goes further it goes underneath the
dimechibility and Diatomaceous
Diatomaceous ooze and there's like a
whole prehistoric ocean thing going down
with the Megalodon but the mega is not a
scientific I don't think that's how it
actually does any attention I think that
is the bottom there yeah I for one would
never even consider diving I I I would
never dive in the ocean but the idea of
diving into something as deep as the
Mariana Trench just seems like ludicrous
to me and I do not have that Spirit of
exploration I have to say well these
guys did it in the name of Science in
the name of Science and in the 1960s
1960s Jesus and Jacques Picard when he
got up he said here in an instant was
the answer the biologists had asked for
decades could life exist in the greatest
steps of the ocean it could which is
incredible because it really kind of
probably widened people's idea of the
kinds of life that could exist you know
life always finds a way to quote Jeff
Goldblum in Jurassic Park life at apps
to like almost any environment every
Niche on Earth is filled by some form of
organism some form of life which is why
I think the ocean is such good fertile
ground for science science fiction you
can invent so much you can speculate on
so many things because we really don't
know what's at the bottom we really
don't really know what could potentially
exist So speaking of things that could
potentially exist in the ocean
what do you think is in the Bermuda
Triangle I generally think that the
Bermuda Triangle is a fun idea
especially when you're like a young
teenager or a kid
um but I don't believe that there's
actually any evidence that there's
anything special about the Bermuda
Triangle from the research that I've
done in my time so I don't really think
there's anything special about it
unfortunately the more I researched the
more I was convinced the Bermuda
Triangle is over over sensationalized I
mean thousands of planes regularly fly
over the Bermuda Triangle every day for
the amount of traffic the triangle gets
there really isn't anything out of the
ordinary there was a study in 2013 where
they identified the world's 10 Most
Dangerous Waters for shipping and trade
and the Bermuda Triangle was not among
those it even include so yeah if there
was something special or paranormal
about the Bermuda Triangle it would be
in the top ten right if there was a
special reason that if there was a if
planes were going down in this
particular region region more than often
or ships were disappearing more than
often yeah I generally think that it's
just a myth it's one of those myths that
doesn't really amount to much when you
do research on it disappearing over the
water does not seem like much of a real
mystery to me yeah because it's at the
bottom of the ocean right like we know
where it is the aircrafts actually
disappear over land in North America
than they do over the ocean that's an
interesting fact well there's a great
episode of BBC's Nova have you seen that
show I have seen it yes there's an
episode in 1976 called The Case of the
Bermuda Triangle I have not seen that
episode well you could watch it for free
on archive.org I'll put a link in the
description for our viewers
but in the episode they they examined
the facts of all these reported
Mysteries and for each one there was a
very plausible answer and most of the
stories they have facts deliberately
taken out by sensationalist authors to
make the account seem more mysterious
such as reports of there being bad
weather and it was at night and the
Coast Guard had no idea where they were
at so they're like omitting things
omitting facts yeah to make it seem like
oh how'd they just vanish out of nowhere
which is which has been a technique
there was a hurricane for a very long
time right
at one point it's worth the watch for
sure there's one point in the
documentary where they're interviewing
one of these authors and they're asking
them where he got his sources and
they're holding up facts to him and you
can visibly see him sweat and gulp as
they are comparing his stories to all
the facts that they have so are you
afraid of the ocean
well the short answer is yeah I honestly
think that I would rather be in outer
space than in a submarine in the ocean
because I feel like when you're in the
ocean and especially if you're like
submerged in the ocean the ocean is
constantly trying to get in and Crush
you to death and kill you and it's
completely inhospitable you can't
breathe and then there's the darkness
also to consider and then there's also
the fact that the ocean is full
of not only Predators but just all sorts
of gigantic swimming things that are so
many times larger than you are even like
whales to me you're terrifying can you
imagine being on a little boat and like
just seeing a big whale come back I've
seen Life of Pi and the movie makes it
look really fun and cool but I'm like it
would not be fun to be on a little boat
and have a whale jump out of the ocean
and do like a little backflip you'd be
freaked out and I just think everything
about the ocean is very horrifying just
the the deepness of it like I said the
Predators or just the idea that the
ocean just sometimes is just very
violent and the waves are rushing and
it's just like so it just feels so
unsafe and so dangerous so yes I'm
terrified of the ocean I'm not the type
of person that's gonna go swim in the
ocean or go surfing or anything I'll get
on a boat but I'm not doing much more
and I have gone snorkeling but that's it
was in very calm Waters and if the water
wasn't calm and if it was deeper Waters
that I would not have done it so yeah
are you afraid of the ocean
I'm terrified of the ocean the only
appropriate answer
when I was a kid I was I was in Hawaii
with my family
and my aunt and uncles who were young
adults at the time took me out
snorkeling on a beach and because they
heard that they were wild dolphins they
wanted to swim with these Dolphins well
we end up swimming a mile out Jesus I
was in fourth grade Oh no just hanging
on for my dear life on a boogie board
seeing these we got to see the dolphin
so that was pretty cool but like the
water was so deep and these Dolphins
would come right up to you and look at
you and I couldn't help but like think
like okay which one of these is a shark
which one of these is a dolphin and
um it just scared me shitless and when
we got back to the shore there were some
people that were about to go swim with
the dolphins but they were like you guys
are really out there like you know
sharks hunt with dolphins so maybe you
did see tiger shark yeah so I probably
there were probably there were
definitely 100 there were sharks out
there so maybe when you were thinking
was that a shark maybe it actually was a
shark exactly so like after that like I
was just I never stepped foot in the
ocean Jesus Christ and then another time
when I was a kid I was snorkeling I was
actually the same year I was snorkeling
in a lake
with my best friend and it was only
about 10 feet deep murky Waters the Sun
was shining through we could see we're
looking at little logs and little fish
and uh we come across this area where
there's a bunch of Fallen trees and I'm
going down looking at them and I see
what I think is branches or sticks
sticking out but they're antlers
gigantic antlers of this Buck dead in
the water and I still have that image in
my head of that dead buck that is
horrifying well you know coming from the
south I don't have the same fear
associated with Lakes compared to the
ocean because we've been swimming in
Lakes is very common in the South but um
the idea of finding something dead
underwater to me is particularly
terrified like a dead body because it's
like there's something about the water
and feeling connected to the dead thing
I feel like it's touching me if I'm in
the same water as it definitely we
didn't get back in after that we just
kind of play than the the waves that is
freaky yeah that was one of the last
times I ever got into it like a body of
water for a while recently I did um go
into the ocean and it was fine for a
little bit but then I decided to swim
around the boat and like look out into
the ocean and I could just see where it
dropped off into Blackness it was like
staring into infinity and I hated it I
wanted to get back on the boat I've
never been that far into the ocean and I
like never would I would never go over
anything that looks black or dark that I
can't see the bottom see when I was
snorkeling the entire time I could see
the bottom and I think I could kind of
see off weighing in the distance that
black drop off area but I knew I was
never gonna go anywhere near there
because just the thought of being over
something so deep just evokes this sense
of just pure dread to me I don't know
what's under that water I don't know
what could come out of that water
anymore so no thank you like when I I
know that shark attacks and things like
that aren't that common
but the fact that they happen is enough
for me and I don't want you to be eating
Alive by something while also being in
water so I'm gonna do whatever I can to
minimize it the vast majority of the
world's oceans remain unexplored
so that's an estimated 80 percent of the
Earth's total area that remains unknown
to us why do you think this is
well I think the first reason is what we
were just talking about because the
ocean is dang scary uh people are afraid
of the ocean and two because the ocean
is very very very very very very
difficult to explore
um people talk about
um space and pressure in outer space the
pressure in spaces is zero the pressure
underwater is something like a thousand
times greater than the pressure on land
so like I said earlier if you're in a
submersible or submarine the ocean is
constantly trying to push its way in and
then we can't dive any deeper than
something like a thousand feet or
something like that I don't even know if
we can get exactly that far but um
yeah so the ocean is is is very
inhospitable and it's very very
difficult to even get deep into the
ocean
um let alone like uh really really like
do any type of exploration and also I
think that at this point in time for
whatever reason humankind has lost a
little bit of its exploratory Spirit
yeah I feel like we went to the moon in
1969 and I feel like since then we've
become less curious as a species in a
lot of ways
um we defund things like NASA we did fun
things like exploratory missions and
scientific things like this
um and that's really a shame and I think
that's part of the reason why the ocean
is not as explored as it could be
because those are not the things that we
emphasize uh those are the things that
the government constantly Cuts money
from programs that would be going on
scientific missions so yeah I think it's
the combination of humankind lacking the
exploratory spirit that it once had and
also the fact that the ocean is very
scary and very difficult to navigate and
exist in and navigating the ocean is
super expensive we could map the entire
bottom of the ocean with sonar but
sonar is such a slow process and it
would cost just as much as sending it
Rover to Mars which is like three
billion dollars so it's not happening
exactly yeah here's another crazy fact
oceans have an estimated 20 million tons
of gold spread throughout the sea floor
Jesus but there's no cost efficient way
of ever retrieving it because if we
could that's enough money to give every
person on the planet nine pounds of gold
but it would cost more to get the gold
than it would it would cost so much more
than it would be worth and I also think
a final reason that probably the ocean
is not as explored as it could be is
because I think that people in general
have the sense that we already know
everything about the ocean I don't think
a lot of people in general understand
the fact that we know almost we not
almost nothing but there's there's a lot
of gaps in our knowledge about what's
actually at the bottom of the ocean and
there's so many organisms and life forms
that we have yet to discover so I think
that's part of the reason why it's not
as explored because there isn't much of
a drive to learn so when did our
fascination with telling stories about
the ocean begin I think it began at the
dawn of mankind the first time we laid
eyes on the ocean and the first time we
considered its Primal mystery because
it's just perfect ground for speculation
and for myth making because like I said
the ocean is angry the ocean is dark it
seems to be mortal it seems to go on
forever
um and what the ancient world was best
at was creating Gods every force of
Nature has a god associated with it and
just and in just about every culture the
ocean has a God or goddesses associated
with it sometimes several so we've
always been making stories about the
ocean
um because it was one of the first
Mysteries that we encountered and it was
always fertile ground for those types of
Stories the ocean represents the end of
the human realm or one of the ends of
the human realm you know so you have the
forest which in a lot of mythologies
represents the end of civilization you
have the sky which represents the end of
the Earthly realm and the beginning of
the heavens and then you of course have
the ocean I think the ocean has so many
qualities that would have seemed worship
worthy to ancient humans uh the ocean is
a bringer of life you know seafood and
fish come out of the ocean and the ocean
is also bringer of death it will
literally drown you it will take your
soul it will take your life force the
ocean is unforgiving when it gets angry
your village might get destroyed your
home might be totally flooded and in the
ancient world because we they really
didn't have a scientific method stories
were all they had to explain the world
and everything that was going on around
them ancient people wrote stories about
things that impacted their day-to-day
lives that's why they wrote stories
about the sun and the forest and the
ocean you talk about the unforgiving
power of the ocean and how it consumes
cities what do you know about Atlantis
I know that Atlantis is one of the most
famous myths that exist
I know that supposedly in some stories
it was around Antarctica I know that it
was an ancient city
that sunk beneath the ocean and I know
that the defining characteristic that
makes it distinct from other ancient
cities that might have been real or
mythological is the fact that it was
very advanced in its technology way more
advanced for city of its supposed time
of existing and that's basically the
stint of my knowledge I think something
that's interesting to know about
Atlantis is that the primary and only
source we have are from two of Plato's
dialogues Timaeus and Cortez so every
other mention of Atlantis is only a
reference to this so there are no
historically accurate mentions there's
no independent no independent sources
besides Plato and Plato never claimed
that Atlantis was a real place in
history it's just something that a
character in his dialogue talks about
because like we said there are sunken
cities that exist real sunken cities
that have sunk into the ocean right but
none of them that were super Advanced so
there might be some truth to it he might
be talking about something that he heard
about but as for Atlantis even Aristotle
who was Plato's student has said that
Plato made Atlantis up for his own
philosophizing purposes so it's most
likely a fictional civilization invented
by Plato
Loosely based on real events and I think
he uses it as like an antithesis of
Athens or his version of the ideal State
yeah of course Atlantis probably had
characteristics of
um a bunch of different cities that
existed because like you said Plato was
drawing from what he knew and things
that he had seen not necessarily talking
about something true but also Plato was
describing this utopian civilization
that possessed technology greater than
his own and this is one of the reasons
why people have always been fascinated
by this Lost Continent it's kind of like
a very primitive sci-fi story it's like
one of the earliest sci-fi stories kind
of and also science sci-fi like I always
say it always relates to something
inherent about Humanity or it always is
trying to teach a lesson about humanity
and I think that when it comes to the
Atlantis story or at least the way the
myth has developed
um over the centuries I think that
hubris human hubris is always associated
with the myth of Atlantis so you have
this very Advanced civilization that
kind of got too big for their own
Bridges and and through their hubris
they destroy themselves is generally the
idea that I tend to see I get in Plato's
original version apparently they were
cursed by gods or they were forsaken by
the gods but generally they are punished
for hubris is a general idea and that is
a concept that we of course see in
science fiction books constantly like we
invent some technology that ultimately
ends up destroying us because we didn't
handle it properly so I think that's a
pretty cool observation well there's a
great essay that I read about where the
myth of Atlantis comes from it's called
another look at Atlantis by Willie lay
it's from an old science fiction mag
magazine in the 1960s called Galaxy
science fiction though this is an essay
it's not Fiction it's rather research on
how the idea of Atlantis came about and
I'll put a link to that article in the
description
so James what are some of the earliest
examples of Science Fiction exploring
the mysteries of the ocean well one of
the most famous early examples is 20 000
Leagues Under the Sea Jules Vermont yeah
yeah 20 000 Leagues Under the Sea it's
uh
it was originally serialized in 1869 so
a chapter of it came out every other
week that kind of explains why it's
written the way it is when you read it
it's very section by section by section
each one like an adventure right and
there's lots of Cliffhangers at the end
of each chapter as well because I want
you to wait for next week every next
week yeah so I actually read this book
recently when we knew we were going to
do this podcast because I had never read
it like most people read this as a kid
so I I went into this as an adult and it
surprised me because I I didn't really
know what it was about I knew that I
knew I had a vague impression that okay
it's a submarine and I think they're
trying to escape a squid I had an
illustrated copy when I was a kid yeah
and I thought that 20 000 Leagues Under
the Sea meant the depth but it actually
refers to the distance that they travel
while Under the Sea yes so the original
French title directly translates to 20
000 Leagues Under the Seas and in
English Tran they translated it to 20
000 Leagues Under the Sea which kind of
implies that they're 20 000 leagues at
the bottom of the scene which is
impossible that would be sixty thousand
miles under the sea the ocean but so the
deepest part we already talked about is
seven miles deep yeah so yeah so 20 000
Leagues Under the seas because it's
about the distance that they travel so
the book starts out with this great
mystery there's this beast in the ocean
that's sinking ships with a point to the
tip so everybody thinks that there's
this killer narwhal out in the ocean and
they set out to kill it and when they
find it they try to Harpoon it and clink
it ends up being metal ends up being a
submarine so I imagine the people that
were reading this week by week because I
don't think it's revealed until chapter
four that what they find is actually a
submarine not an animal I bet you that
was quite the twist back in 1869 and it
is the submarine of none other than
Captain Nemo Captain Nemo and the
submarines called the Nautilus a
nautilus yeah now the cap both Captain
Nemo and the Nautilus have been
referenced in so much popular fiction
I'm sure you've heard those names before
even if you've never read Twenty
Thousand Leagues Under the Sea so what's
interesting about 20 000 Leagues Under
the Sea is that it's operating on
archaic assumptions of science to make
kind of things happen to make things
work you know like like the way Jules
Verne kind of I think understood the
ocean and understood technology that
could explore the ocean is different
from what would be scientifically
accurate today and yet he did make some
seemingly accurate predictions about
certain things right like the idea of a
large durable and heavily weaponized
submarine seemed completely far-fetched
When It Was Written but his vision of a
ship running entirely on electrical
power came true during the
implementation of Naval submarines in
the 20th century he also describes a
weapon called the laden ball which is a
bullet of glass and steel charged with
electricity
and we have a similar device now but it
functions on land and it's a non-lethal
weapon shoots electrified rounds kind of
like a stun gun and then there's also
the giant squid the Giants which isn't
really technology and of course Jules
Verne wasn't the first person ever to be
like a colossal squid exists but I
definitely think that he
popularized that idea with 20 000
Leagues Under the Sea and the colossal
squid turned out to be real it's
something that we discovered within the
last I think 20 15 20 years so the
colossal squid is absolutely a real
thing but we very very rarely see them
because they're all the way at the
bottom of the ocean and when we do see
them they're usually sick and dying so
the best footage that we actually have
of a colossal squid it's very close to
the surface and you can visibly see that
it is in the process of dying because
they rarely rarely rarely ever surface
some people point to 20 000 leagues as
the book that may have sparked the
ecological movement because when it was
published oceans reviewed as limit list
supplies of bounty like in the 19th
century several species of whales were
nearly driven to extinction because of
the whaling industry
but throughout the book the ocean is
described as having an intricate balance
of marine life it gives an appreciation
for the complexity of the ocean
ecosystem this is why I love science
fiction and science fiction authors
because they're constantly changing the
way the world sees things what Jules
Verne did with 20 000 Leagues Under the
Sea reminds me of what happened with the
Frank Herbert's Dune although it's to a
lesser degree with Dune because Dune
definitely inspired this whole
ecological movement in science fiction
and definitely started a wave of people
thinking about ecology in the 1960s
almost 100 years after Jules Verne I
just think it's really interesting that
two science fiction authors 100 years
apart can do something similar through
their fiction work so one of our
favorite quotes from 20 000 Leagues
Under the Sea is a quote that Captain
Nemo says the sea does not belong to
tyrants on its surface they can still
stake their evil claims
battle each other devour each other haul
every Earthly horror but 30 feet below
sea level their power ceases their
influence Fades their domination
vanishes ah sir live live in the heart
of the Seas here alone do I find
Independence here I recognize no
superiors here I am free
and I just think it's a great quote that
kind of like speaks to who Captain Nemo
is as a character and he is a character
that Jules Verne develops in a later
book right yeah
um there's actually a sequel to the book
called The Mysterious Island and it
reveals more about Captain Nemo in this
book there's people stranded on an
island and they find out that the
Mysterious Island they're on is actually
Captain Nemo's Hideout and it's the Home
Port of the Nautilus in this book he's
on his deathbed and he Reveals His true
identity because in 20 000 Leagues Under
the Sea Captain Nemo super mysterious
nobody knows where he came from what his
intentions are the other characters in
the book are his prisoners
um and in the end he ends up killing a
bunch of people so finally in this book
we learned that he is a lost Indian
Prince of Dakar after a failed Rebellion
he escapes to a deserted island with 20
of his compatriots where they built the
Nautilus so that's a really interesting
fact and I definitely never knew that
about Captain Nemo I never even knew
there was a sequel to 20 000 Leagues
Under the Sea so that is a super
interesting fact I don't think people
knew that it was a sequel when it came
out either it was like a big reveal and
towards the middle of the book that oh
this is Captain Nemo this is where he's
been and we get to finally know why he
did the things that he did interesting
so if you haven't read 20 000 leagues in
the sea I definitely think it's still an
interesting read if you are a lover of
Science Fiction yeah I enjoyed it as an
adult I thought it was a kid's book I
recently read it but one thing you
should know about me is I love old books
so I love the way that it read
absolutely and speaking of old books
let's talk about
Lovecraft okay so why do you think
Lovecraft chose the ocean as a backdrop
in his vision of Cthulhu
I think it is pretty freaking obvious is
because the ocean is big enough and
Grand enough and deep enough and dark
enough and mysterious enough to house
something as monstrous and ancient and
as Eldridge as Cthulhu and the other old
ones Lovecraft was playing on the
inherent mystery that already exists
that's already associated with the ocean
the old ones in his story are basically
adopting the fear that the ocean evokes
this that's a part of the fear that
Cthulhu evokes so it's just an excellent
backdrop and also the ocean is the only
example of something that we have in
nature that can take something as large
as a city the idea as we said before of
a sunken city is something that exists
um and the ocean is really one of the
only things in nature that has the
concept of returning something things
come out of the ocean all the time
return to land so I think the idea that
the ocean can take something and then
and return at eons later and it can
bring devastating consequences is
already something that was kind of
present in Humanity's Collective
Consciousness and it was fertile ground
for Lovecraft to play upon so what
metaphors can be interpreted from the
rise and return of Cthulhu or what does
Cthulhu represent so the thing about
Cthulhu is that his return is certain he
is asleep right now he's waiting at the
bottom of the ocean but one day when the
stars realign themselves he will awaken
and it's guaranteed whether or not we
choose to believe in it now I think that
Cthulhu can be seen to represent
Humanity's fear of something great in
the future that is beyond our control
it is the fear that we are not in
control of our own destiny that we are
not in control of our own fate that
there are things that move with greater
force than we can resist I think that is
the essential fear that the rise of
Cthulhu in the story represents and I
think that is the essential fear that
Cthulhu represents the dark judge of
mankind in the story Call of Cthulhu
there's people that start having visions
of Raleigh and Cthulhu like why are
those specific people why were they
chosen I think there is
a very clear implication from the story
and it's basically that these certain
individuals were open they were open in
some way like they were artists they
were open to the either they were open
to receive
um this intention you know a lot of
people think or there's this idea that
all art that all creativity is is pulled
from some ethereal realm and you have to
be open to receive you know the gift the
blessing of like this knowledge you have
to be open it's you know the the ancient
idea of a muse you know what I mean so
you're open to the intention
um and so I think that's why the certain
people freaked out it was people that
were available you know I mean people
that were open to be influenced by the
thoughts of the old ones
um because the old one the book mentions
that the old ones language was not a
language
that we could really comprehend it was a
language of thought it was kind of like
a psionic language that was transmitted
in a way that we really didn't
understand so why does the ocean cut off
the old ones from these people's dreams
I think that is Lovecraft paying homage
to the power and the spiritual force of
the ocean itself
I don't remember the exact quote but in
the Call of Cthulhu it says something
like the Primal mystery of the ocean cut
off the spectral intercourse for
whatever reason
um the psionic power that thought energy
that the old ones was were sending off
to communicate with mankind the ocean
blocked it
um
and I just I just really think that's oh
my that I really think that is Lovecraft
Pango much of the power of the ocean and
recognizing that the ocean has something
greater than the even the old ones can
check well because and and that is
aligned with the rest of his Mythos
because we know that the old ones are
subject to the forces of nature they can
only move between the Stars when the
stars are aligned properly and I guess
something similar applied to the ocean
well that's interesting because radio
waves we use all the time they can be
used to explore space but they don't
work in the ocean the water gets in the
way that's interesting and this might be
kind of loose because we talk about the
predictive power of Science Fiction but
that's almost almost there I guess
spectral intercourse of the old ones
isn't exactly radio waves but you can
see kind of the connection there that's
a funny fact so why did Raleigh sink to
the bottom of the ocean
and how did it rise back up the heavy
implication in the book is that it had
to do with the alignment of the Stars
the old ones are heavily subject to the
alignment of the Stars when the stars
are right they can leap a boundless
between the stars and when the stars are
wrong they are imprisoned and they
become beings that can only communicate
through thought so it was the alignment
of the stars and for whatever reason
something happened in the cosmic
alignment and the stars were in the
right alignment for a very brief amount
of time in the story and then maybe came
out of alignment so Cthulhu wasn't awake
he was only awake for several hours
instead of like for a new eternity so
yeah that was that's essentially the
basic reason and of course Lovecraft is
a little vague with some of the things
he doesn't want to give you too much but
if I had to speculate as to a reason it
seems that the text heavily implies that
do you think it's possible that Raleigh
might be an ancient spaceship that's a
cool concept well it does say that the
old ones came from outer space the outer
Cosmos and it also does say that they
brought things with them like it says
they brought their images with them and
they brought like strange medals and
things with them so could Raleigh be a
spaceship it very well could because
where did the metal come from anywhere
where the material come from and then
relay is is mentioned to have all these
strange angles and to be like really
weird and you turn a corner and then it
doesn't make sense it's just like it's
it's a very weird uh kind of like
brutalist structure I don't even know if
brutalist is the right word but it's
just a very weird structure that doesn't
make sense he uses the term
non-euclidean non-euclidean is the term
it uses in in the book so
um it's a very it is a very alien
structure so the idea that it is a
spaceship is an interesting concept
because where did it come from now is
Cthulhu even concerned with human
Affairs at all no not particularly it's
kind of like
if they're there he's gonna use them to
do what he needs you know what I mean
he's he's not really concerned but I
mean are humans really concerned
with any of the organisms or things that
we make use of without really thinking
about it it's like that I think are you
concerned with the blade of grass we
grow it still you're not that concerned
you don't care about the blade of grass
really as an individual so I don't
really think he's he's not really
concerned no the the old ones the
ancient beings their motives
um can be assumed to be far more complex
than we can even comprehend what Cthulhu
wants and what Cthulhu is actually doing
is beyond Us in the in the story he's
called something like the great priest
or the great sorcerer or something like
that he cast spells that cause some kind
of change or effect on the universe
that's incomprehensible to us as Mankind
and I think that's um that's a part of
it that's part of what makes it scary
and we don't we don't get to know
exactly what's going on we go through
Lane what he's actually thinking about
so then what is Cthulhu
so what is Cthulhu and I feel like we've
been talking about Cthulhu for a while
Without Really explaining what he is
so Cthulhu is one of the great old ones
and in lovecraft's work there are
several several beings and uncounted
number of beings that have existed for
eons and eons and eons and eons and eons
and the cosmos is their domain and they
are the the beings and the forces that
rule the cosmos and because the cosmos
is so big and so diverse we rarely ever
see them but they are still here and
they're sometimes in other dimensions
and Cthulhu is one of such beings that
Waits on Earth that he's been here be
long before the domain of mankind right
he was he was the first ruler ever the
old ones were the first rulers of Earth
so long before we were even thought
about he was there and he waited so
that's the concept of Cthulhu and he's
from somewhere in space initially as I
said so that's what he is like what he I
don't know what he's what is he made of
physically that's an interesting
question because in the novel in the
short story there's a there's a there's
a part where a ship moves through
Cthulhu and body reforms together almost
like he's made of like something like
gelatin it's almost like he's not even
he doesn't exist in Flesh and Blood The
Way That We Exist he's something else
he's something that almost we can't even
even begin to conceptualize or
understand like we could never kill
Cthulhu with a bomb or an explosion like
in the movie underwater well we don't
know if he dies but we could never like
attack Cthulhu like with with Mortal
technology so Lovecraft has another
story of the Cthulhu Mythos called
Shadow over in his mouth where he
introduces these aquatic creatures come
from the ocean called The Deep one the
Deep ones what are the Deep ones well
the Deep ones are these creatures that
live in the ocean they are not
old ones but there are several beings in
Lovecraft Smith those that aren't quite
old ones but they are beings that know
of old ones or worshiped old ones just
like Twisted creatures and they
sometimes come out of the ocean and
breed with humans and get up to
Shenanigans and they worship Dagon
um and Eldritch Horror that exists in
the ocean
so that is basically the deal with the
Deep ones and the Deep ones have been I
think they've been referenced more
outside of Lovecraft than they actually
were within lovecraft's Mythos George R
Martin
um has deep ones in his stories he calls
them the swishers and in The Song of Ice
and Fire books the idea of the deep
Watts has just been used in a lot of
places so what fear do you think the
Deep ones represent well in Lovecraft
stories
I think the Deep ones represent a very
specific fear that comes out of one of
lovecraft's I think personal flaws
um and it's the fear of Tainted
bloodline
someone shot over in his mouth the big
twist is that the main character spoiler
alert is is part deep one and he's
beginning his transformation to become a
deep one and that's one of the tropes in
lovecraft's mythos's tainted bloodline a
character has has this has this tainted
um ancestry
um and and I think that might have come
out of lovecraft's xenophobia or because
we we do know that he was a very
xenophobic person I mean we can separate
the art from the artist but to some
degree it does seep in I think it in
part does come from that place but I do
also think that it is an effective tool
for horror you know the idea that your
part Swisher the idea that you're part
monster
um and the Deep ones also represent a
fear that I actually talked about in my
last Halloween special
um it's the same theater that created
The Craze
um in the mid
1900s uh of the aliens are coming for
our women the Deep ones want to come and
take our women and breed and mix with us
so I think at the core the idea does
stem from xenophobia like add it to root
and I don't know if that is
um that's not necessarily the root in
every manifestation but at the core I
think that's where that fear comes from
and that's the fear that Lovecraft
intended them to represent do you know
of any good adaptations of lovecraft's
Cthulhu Mythos
good no but worth the watch
um okay underwater is not a good movie
in my opinion underwater with Kristen
Stewart Christian Stewart it came out in
2020 I think it's not a very good movie
but what is cool is that there is an
awesome looking Cthulhu monster and a
bunch of like deep ones at the end of it
and it looks awesome I mentioned this a
little bit earlier because they try to
bomb Cthulhu at the end I'm like you
can't bomb Cthulhu give me a break
Cthulhu would eat that explosion but um
yeah like I would say if you want to
watch the whole movie sure watch it but
if you want to just like if it's
streaming somewhere you want to just
like skip to the last 20 minutes just so
you can see the cool Cthulhu monster I
would say that because the movie kind of
does drag and if you've seen alien then
you you know this movie already
um just yeah it's very derivative I
think the same premise but underwater
yeah but it does have that cool Cthulhu
monster and I really wish there was I
actually think that Cthulhu more than a
lot of other Lovecraft stories would
lend itself to adaptation very very well
the way it's written it could be a great
miniseries well what a good adaptation
of that look like well I think you would
you would start off the same way that
you do
in the story you would have the main
character going through his uncle's
things and then every episode can be one
of the things that he's reading about
because he he reads about like several
different events that evolve that
involve this cult and that involve
Cthulhu so like each episode three or
four episodes can be one of those events
and then him like going in and out
thinking about things I think that would
work very effectively I think there's a
lot of mystery in that story I think
it's just a very well written story it's
definitely very talked about for a
reason not only is Cthulhu very
interesting I think that Call of Cthulhu
is probably lovecraft's best short story
I really do think it is
um so yeah I think it if you structure
it right make it a mini series I think
that could really really work
um and also that just just so many great
scenes that would just work so well on
screen uh the cult scene when you got
the the the the cops going through the
jungle and finding the cult
um when they're interviewing the cult
members
um just just all of it just the the
flashbacks to the archaeological Society
I think it would really work as a mini
series so HBO get on that
[Music]
so let's talk about some of the concepts
found in science fiction surrounding the
potential of underwater exploration
survival and technology and the
potential benefits and problems that
could arise so why would humans build a
society under the sea
cool question
so actually one of my favorite favorite
graphic novels ever by Rick reminder and
Greg tuccini
low deals with this very idea and in low
the sun has gotten very very big it's
expanding and the Earth has become very
hot so humans have migrated to under the
ocean and they live in these big domes
and it's just a great graphic novel and
it's really cool so I think if the Earth
was damaged in some way or if the Earth
got too hot
um it's probably completely impractical
probably no real reason that we would
ever do that we probably like probably
go to a different planet before we
develop the technology to live at the
bottom of the ocean wool and low they
can't get to another planet that
technology doesn't exist yet or that it
does exist but they haven't found a
suitable plan so they're waiting
underwater until
they can but also in low I think Lowe is
is very Fantastical and it's not meant
to really make real scientific right
since it's very like Fantastical it is
science fiction but it's not hard
science fiction by any means like we
have people like in diving suits at the
bottom of the ocean where the pressure
would totally crush them could not work
but yeah I think I think it's still a
very good series and it's about family
and it's about Hope and it's about
person perseverance the perseverance of
the human spirit it's about what keeps
us going and and it's about like what
connects us as human beings and I think
that it's it's probably a masterpiece
and I feel like it's so underrated that
I promote it whenever I can so speaking
of low do you think there would be any
social or psychological challenges
people will face living underwater
isolated from the world above
absolutely
um and that's and actually that's
definitely something that low goes into
I mean we evolved on the surface
that's who we are so like isolated in
these shells underwater I think that
humankind loses a part of its Spirit its
inherent soul and we see
in low that these domes show all the
signs of a Dying society and that's also
that's also because their society is
literally dying like there's technical
filtration problems with their air
system but like still I think that just
not seeing the sun would fundamentally
change who we are as people and and a
few science fiction things deal with
this concept you know we got like a silo
um based on the series wool and then
we've got uh The City of Ember which was
one of my favorites growing up
um which was about these people that
lived underground they had been down
there for like hundreds of years and
they had never seen the Sun and although
they don't know it there is something
that they've lost there's there's
something that's missing we evolved to
be under the Sun so I just think
inherently by being under the ocean we
do lose something if that was ever
something that happened how do you think
being underwater would differ from the
isolation of being in space
well like I mentioned earlier
I feel like the ocean the pressure you I
feel like you could almost feel the
pressure of the water trying to get in
you know what I mean there's something
about space to me
or I'm not as I'm nowhere near as afraid
of being in outer space than being an
ocean I would rather be in like a Sandra
Bullock gravity situation
than being stranded underwater there's
something so devastating and dark about
the ocean It Feels So enclosed and
claustrophobic whereas space feels very
open it feels like I'm I'm looking out
into Endless Possibilities I'm floating
in the heavens whereas like being
underwater feels like I'm in the
Underworld it feels like I'm trapped
contained at the bottom of all existence
at the lowest level of reality so I
don't know maybe that's just a
psychological feeling in my mind but
that's what that's that's the feeling
that I get so there's a book I read that
kind of goes into all this called
starfish by Peter Watts have you read
that one I have not but I have read
blind sight and echopraxia yeah you've
done some videos on some Peter Watts
books yeah well this is kind of similar
to Blind sight starfish it's set
underwater in a deep ocean power station
and they're harvesting energy from a
geothermal vent along a tectonic shift
and what's interesting about it is this
place is staffed by people who have been
radically adapted for deep sea labor so
they can swim and breathe underwater and
survive immense pressure and they call
these people rifters weird it is weird
and the corporation that has this power
station they find out that people tend
to go insane from the isolation of being
miles underwater so they specifically
select people who are used to being
under stress and who have been through
trauma so that they can easily adapt
pretty screwed up honestly right so I
mean they I think there's like 12
characters under there and they're
they're all have very strong
personalities and it's it's about what
they find down there and how they
interact with each other it's about a
lot of things like all of his books but
it takes place underwater and um Peter
Watts actually made this series
available for free on his website
ah well I love Peter Watts so I'm
definitely gonna probably be picking
that up because I really enjoyed the
other two books of his that I read and I
do like underwater stuff I think
underwater stuff could be very scary so
I'm going to check that one out
so do you think intelligent life can
exist underwater and what might that
look like well do I think that
intelligent life could have already
evolved under it's two questions right
sure so I do I think intelligent life
already exists underwater do I think it
could exist underwater in the future so
do I think there's already evolved
intelligent life underwater I don't know
maybe I just saw a documentary about
people trying to talk to whales oh yeah
um and that was pretty interesting even
though the documentary wasn't that great
but the Apple TV yeah the idea of people
talking to whales the idea that these
creatures could have potentially complex
speech and I think that's that we get
very we're very like kind of we're
egomaniacs as humans like we we like of
course they couldn't have complex
language maybe they do maybe we just
don't understand it maybe they don't
feel the need to try and communicate
with us so maybe and like I said there's
thing the ocean is really really deep
and we don't know what's totally in
there so maybe there are intelligent
things in the ocean second part of the
question
could we like create life that goes in
the ocean through like bioengineering
and stuff like that like in the movie
Deep Blue Sea where we put like a human
brain inside of a shark potentially
um I feel like when it comes to genetic
engineering that's that's a new frontier
of Science and I think that's going to
be a very weird thing I feel like a lot
of us
are hyper focused on like Ai and Aliens
when genetic engineering is going to be
like a weird thing that totally changes
the future of humanity so we we might be
having fish humans that live in the
ocean before long
have you heard of aquatic ape Theory I
have heard of aquatic history but tell
me about it well when I was a kid there
was this what I thought was a
documentary I was flipping through
channels this was before Netflix I just
came across in the middle of this
documentary called mermaids the Body
Found oh it was like it was like on
Animal Planet or National Geographic I
thought I saw that it was real I thought
it was real that I I posted on Facebook
and I told everyone I was like magic
exists you have to watch this
documentary everything's about to change
it turns out yeah I had to delete that
post but it's a fake documentary but the
theory that they use in that document
Theory aquatic ape theory is a real
Theory but
yeah okay oh yeah you're right you're
right so like people have talked about
this before it's the idea that there's a
species of ape that went back into the
ocean and evolved to live in the sea
kind of like a mermaid so like as we
like evolve to like live on land they
evolved they like kind of like win
reverse and evolve to like live in the
water and they develop like fins and
yeah they went back to their Roots they
went back well you know there there are
species that have done that like I'm
pretty sure whales and uh Wales for sure
used to be wolves yes I know that yeah
um platypuses are super weird too
they're like some weird hybrid they like
lay eggs and they're they're very
bizarre well if aquatic ape theory is
true
they probably wouldn't look like
mermaids in fact the uh the manatee is
probably more what Apes would look like
if they evolved back into the ocean
interesting so we have the the idea of
mermaids like Ariel The Little Mermaid
or like Daryl Hannah and splash
but I've always thought that if we had a
real mermaids they'd look more like the
ones in Harry Potter and the Goblet of
Fire the movie because those things look
like they evolved in water they don't
really look like people with Tails
they've kind of got more like shark
tails almost which makes more sense than
I think the the flippy whale looking
tail that our Ariel The Little Mermaid
has so yeah that's kind of what I've
imagined them like and that's kind of
what they look like in that fake
documentary the bodies found or whatever
it was called that I totally got tricked
by as well so yeah do you think it would
be easier or harder to find
commonalities with intelligent creatures
from the ocean compared to ones we might
find in space well well really there's
no telling but in general I would say
it'll be easier to communicate with
creatures from the ocean because we
would have the same evolutionary tree
right where it's like things from space
they could be very very different from
us very different everything on Earth we
we think we assume everything on Earth
we have a basis of connection to we
share DNA so immediately there's that
we're on like the same ground there
could be things from outer space that
aren't even made of what we're made of
so yeah I think in general probably the
ocean would be easier well I just read a
great book that just came out called the
mountain and the Sea by Ray Naylor have
you heard of that one I have heard of
that one and I follow him on threads and
he follows me on threads nice you should
come on the podcast he should his new
book at the mountain and the Sea though
is crazy good it's about a lot of things
but it's mainly about the scientist that
is attempting to communicate with
intelligent life in the ocean like
fathom yeah except for in this story
there octopuses whoa yeah something as
different it's not octopus
both are correct okay octopuses octopi
um octopods interesting yeah we're all
all right
but OCTA octopi or octopuses
they're like the most alien creatures in
the sea they're [__] weird right so
this book is about attempting to
communicate with this species they find
like I said it's about a lot of things
there's one part
um that takes place on a really creepy
boat that's run completely by AI with
human slaves and
frightening but I don't want to say too
much about the book because I think it's
best to go in not knowing too much about
it and just experience this world that
Ray Naylor has created I do want to read
a quote from it because the pros in this
book is just spectacular we came from
the ocean and we only Survive by
carrying salt water with us all our
lives in our blood in our cells the sea
is our true home this is why we find the
shore so calming We Stand where the
waves break like Exiles returning home
wow there definitely is an inherent
calming
feature of the ocean like standing on
the shore it's very common and even if
the water is kind of Russia for some
reason being there and standing by the
shore is very calming so that's very
true but I really think you should read
this book and make a Quinn's ideas video
on it
there's a lot of Concepts you can make
several videos it's definitely on my
list and I've already told Ray that I'm
gonna do it so yeah nice yeah I'm
definitely going to read the book
because I love anything with octopuses
in it because octopi are very they're
just weird and so just like alien very
alien-like I've heard people claim that
octopuses don't actually originate from
Earth I've heard that too which is very
weird and I don't know about that I feel
like we can test their DNA because
that's the DNA I'm sure we have but they
are very alien-like the way they behave
right like do you know about the octopus
brain now once some of the ox was broken
okay so like octopus they have eight
limbs and all those limbs operate on a
completely independent nervous system I
did hear that I didn't know that so they
have like a central brain that gives
commands and then each arm decides how
to accomplish that task like imagine if
you're like oh I want a cheeseburger
right now and you look over and one of
your hands is bringing you a
cheeseburger ah yeah that's kind of
creepy so if like in if an octopus loses
a limb is that limb like smile aware of
like I don't know if it's aware but like
if you chop off an octopus's leg it like
still waves around right yeah Jesus and
how scientists discover this is is weird
they um they severed the nerves and the
arms from the central brain and then
tickled them ah and they felt the
tickles that's so weird and bizarre and
interesting another thing that's alien
about octopuses they have blue blood
that is super weird yeah right so our
blood is red because we we have
hemoglobin which contains iron and when
it's oxygen oxygenated turns red
octopuses have hemocyanin which is a lot
like hemoglobin but it contains copper
and when copper is exposed to oxygen it
turns blue weird I feel like a weird
fact about octopus or a cool fact about
them is like how they can kind of
squeeze through like almost anything
they're all muscle they don't have any
bones oh that is they're so squishy what
makes them so strong too while their
arms are just nothing but muscle it
makes you wonder how like an organism
like this could even exist well I don't
think something like this could exist on
land
but in water and that's the funny thing
about octopus too is because they can
leave the water unlike the majority of
sea creatures they can totally leave the
water for a limited amount of time I
mean not not permanently but they can
which is really interesting I wonder I'm
not a scientist so I don't I wonder how
that feature of the octopuses evolved
because why were they leaving land why
do they have that ability why do
octopuses well I think a lot of
octopuses live close to shore so if the
tide goes out and they're kind of stuck
and they have a I can Scuttle back in if
they need to okay that would be my guess
but octopuses can survive in low oxygen
because they have three hearts two that
yeah and they have two that pump blood
to the gills and one that pumps blood
everywhere else now to keep those gills
oxygenated have you seen any videos of
octopuses on YouTube changing colors
yeah I totally see insane it's like how
does this happen in nature like it's
incredible like I I don't know and and
the Precision with which they change
color is what's impressive to me it's
just it's just so bizarre and weird it's
a it's a it's a phenomenal adaptation I
think yeah octopuses are one of the
weirdest animals on the face of the
planet another thing that's cool about
them are their eyes their eyes operate
with a single lens that can change shape
and adjust to focus so like imagine
instead of having glasses you can just
like squeeze your eyes and focus in on
what you want whatever you want yeah in
fact by studying the octopus's eyes
that's how when we came up with better
camera technology that's super that's a
fun fact interesting do you know
anything about the mating habits of the
octopus not really I know that like some
octopus like mothers like literally will
like stay with their eggs until they
literally die of starvation but as far
as like how they mate I don't know
hella funny
so male octopi one of their arms is
their sexual organ
what right yeah so it doubles as an arm
and a sexual organ and they use that to
fertilize the eggs though the majority
of the time the male octopus doesn't
really wants to be around the female
octopi because they're very solitary
creatures so they will rip off their arm
and give it to a female it's like here
you go and the female will hold on to it
and keep it for as long as she needs and
then when she's ready she'll fertilize
her eggs with it there's weirder [__] in
the ocean honestly I mean there's
there's like that species of fish where
the male will attach itself to the
female and it'll just merge into its
body and it'll just be like a permanent
supply of sperm so much weird stuff on
the ocean
yeah well that's bizarre but the
craziest thing about the octopus
is that it uses tools there have been
some species of octopuses that have been
observed using coconut halves as armor
which is really strange for an animal to
do because when it picks up the Coconuts
there isn't an immediate Advantage you
know it's more of a burden to carry
around these coconuts so just the fact
that they are collecting objects for
future use is a sign of great
intelligence that's so interesting
because people tend to think that tool
use is the domain of humanity and
Humanity alone
but this is kind of saying that it's not
I mean we're still I guess the only
species that creates tools but tool use
is not our domain alone so yeah the
octopus they're the alien of the sea
those alien octopuses
so what do you think
is hiding in the depths of the ocean
we can't say but certainly I'm not gonna
be the one to find out I'll leave that
to people that are braver than me I
think there is a lot of Darkness I think
there's probably several species of
things that we've yet to uncover there's
probably a bunch of sunken cities and
sunken ships and a bunch of lost history
um
probably not Cthulhu at least I don't
wanna I don't want there to be a Cthulhu
Cthulhu might be there because they
won't be there we have a recording of
Cthulhu called the bloop the bloop have
you heard of the bloop
I have heard of the bloop
so the bloop was basically a sound that
we heard from the ocean that we thought
for a long time came from some immense
living creature at the bottom of the
ocean and the reason that it's extra
creepy is because of the coordinates of
it they're
very very close to where Lovecraft wrote
that relay had sunk into the ocean so
like if you look at on a map where the
coordinates of the bloop is and the
coordinates of where relay supposedly
was it's very close it's almost like is
this the Call of Cthulhu but what do you
have about the bloop well
it's not Cthulhu I'm sorry I knew that
but it was discovered in 1997 by the
NOAA which is kind of like the NASA of
the ocean and it's just an ultra low
frequency with high amplitude that they
detected underwater
um so you can listen to a recording of
This that the NOAA released but it's
released at 16 times the speed that way
the human ears can hear it
um let me play it for you
foreign
so it just sounds like a bloop it's
literally a blue it literally sounds
like a blue now that's 16 times the
speed though
um people have slowed it down on YouTube
and it sounds much more frightening let
me play just a little bit of that for
you
yeah definitely go through them no
question about it whatever they say it
is it's not it's Cthulhu the government
found it and they know what relay is and
they're freaking out about it well
everything else is a distraction it's
good but we have the evidence what do
you mean no no the only reason that
people think that it's a creature is
because a scientist from the NOAA was
doing an interview and he said that he
did not believe the bloop to be man-made
and then he goes on to say that it
shared a similar audio profile to that
of a living creature you have it you got
it creature living creature however the
sound of it is much more powerful than
any known creature yeah they got it it's
it's the biggest living creature ever
Cthulhu but people hyper focus on that
sentence because immediately after he
attributes the sound to
ice calving in Antarctica like an Ice
Quake and they have discovered that the
sound did animate from an iceberg
cracking and breaking away from an
Antarctic Glacier so essentially he
basically said that it sounds like a
living creature but there's nothing that
big that could make that sound so it's
probably just cracking sea ice and then
later they confirmed that it was
cracking sea ice yes but if you want to
believe it's Cthulhu that's that's a lot
that's fine
it's just I I totally get why it costs
so much hubbub in the HP Lovecraft
community at the time because of like
the location of it and because of like
especially what the slowed down version
of it sounds like the bloop is is a
really is it really interesting event a
really interesting thing that occurred
yeah but in all seriousness hopefully
Cthulhu is not at the bottom of the
ocean but you know what is hiding at the
bottom of the ocean maybe we don't maybe
we'll never know and I for one
I would rather look to the Stars than
look to the ocean I know the ocean is
important I know the mysteries of our
planet are important but at my core like
I am a Star Trek fan I am a fan of the
idea of space exploration it's what it's
what gets me very excited I want to see
the stars the ocean scares me the Stars
excite me
[Music]
so thanks for listening to the cosmic
Chronicles podcast you can subscribe to
our podcast on Spotify Apple podcast
Google podcast or wherever you listen to
your podcast we also have a YouTube
channel that you can check out and don't
forget new episodes every other Friday
thanks so much for listening
foreign
[Music]